una jornada diplomática y de acusaciones
el presidente ucraniano y visitó la
Corte Penal Internacional en Países
Bajos allí pidió la conformación de un
tribunal especial para juzgar a Rusia
no aceptaremos ningún formato híbrido de
tribunal trabajaremos en un nuevo
tribunal para asegurarnos que quienes
dieron órdenes rindan cuentas por
crímenes asesinatos torturas y no
permanezcan Intocables
también aseguró que falta poco para la
contraofensiva por su parte Rusia señaló
Estados Unidos de estar detrás del
presunto atentado con drones este
miércoles en el edificio de gobierno del
kremlin sabemos muy bien que las
decisiones sobre tales acciones sobre
tales ataques terroristas no se hacen en
kiev sino en Washington y kiev hace lo
que se le dice que haga sabemos que a
menudo incluso los objetivos en sí
mismos no están determinados por kiev
sino que se determinan en Washington y
luego se llevan a kiev para que kiev los
implemente
tras las explosiones que según agencias
rusas tenían el objetivo de asesinar a
Vladimir Putin el mandatario tuvo
reuniones con normalidad la cancillería
china también reaccionó todas las partes
deben evitar tomar cualquier acción que
pueda causar una mayor escalada y desde
la Unión Europea su máximo representante
diplomático giuseppey instó a Rusia no
utilizar el episodio como una excusa
para escalar la guerra